[Music]
the book is a huge success and
fascinating you talk about your time as
a member of SEAL team 3 yes sir
okay and this is it tell us attrition
between size SEAL team 3 and SEAL team 6
we've all heard about SEAL team 6 or the
ones that that killed bin Laden bin
Laden and they and they uh yeah I forgot
who they killed some guy they just
carried out another operation just days
ago so what's the difference between
SEAL team 3 and SEAL team 6
well you originally you have SEAL team 1
still team two
right and then they formed up this
special unit that was called SEAL team 6
right since then so many guys been
coming in we've been building up the
forces that they started filling in the
rest of the numbers and to go from one
of the other SEAL Teams yeah to six you
basically have to go through another
boot camp tryout and go there did you
want to be in SEAL Team six at the time
I did not but looking back at it yes I
wish I would have right because that's
pretty cool now to Walker I mean first
of all you've got an amazing story so
you shouldn't you know you got nothing
to be ashamed of but it might may be fun
to walk into a bar now and go sail team
six huh I do that a lot I just tell
people I was on that raid and no one
believes it but then I give details they
just aren't you know we got them in
Baltimore I am amazed by by some of the
things that you've accomplished you are
an incredible sniper and you're the
longest targets the target that you hit
in combat was I was think about this
today
twenty-one hundred yards away which is
21 football fields away yes sir that I
can't even understand making a shot from
that distance I can't either it is an
accident it was an accident dropped your
rifle
I set it up I accidentally pulled the
trigger and the guy went down but but I
mean this is something where you're in
battle and what the the technology
behind it first of all the the the
weapons themselves are incredible but
there's a lot of calculating wind
there's actual computers involved oh
there are I mean our optics and
everything are so much more advanced
than the guys had and even Vietnam which
you got Carlos Hathcock who I think is
the greatest sniper of all time I have
more kills but that doesn't mean I'm
better than he is I was just put in a
position where I had more opportunities
but yeah and I definitely cheated I used
ballistic ballistic computer that tells
me everything to do so I'm just a monkey
on a gun okay well I wouldn't go that
far but I have a question because this
kind of thing fascinates me when I want
it when you're in your snipers position
how long can you be in your position
before you start to get paranoid that
they're going to hone in on where you're
shooting from and come after you well if
you're inside the city then depends if
you take an occupied house or unoccupied
if you take occupied then you have to
take the family feed them make them go
to the bathroom all this other stuff
let them do everything just can't let
them go outside by 9:00 o'clock in the
morning they know you're there if it's
unoccupied then by the time you take
your first shot they know where you are
and then you you move on
you can't move you're in the middle of
the city that's why when I go in I don't
go in alone I take my team with me and
once I take my shot now it's a defensive
position okay well you were so well
known by the Iraqi insurgents that you
were fighting that they put a twenty
thousand dollar bounty on your head is
that right yes sir okay you don't have
to call me sir by the way I'm a I'm a
talk show host
you're here and I'm here that's great
but but $20,000 bounty on your head how
did the Iraqi insurgents identify who
you were when I'd go into a house and we
had the occupied houses I would take the
top of my uniform off and just have my
short-sleeved shirt on and you can see
my tattoo coming down the arm and they
identified that with me and started
every time someone would be shot by a
sniper in the area they associated that
with me so they they came after you and
they started to actually say someone
please take this guy out and you'll make
$20,000 well the 20,000 they were
definitely putting the Association with
me but it was all snipers had $20,000
bounty on their head okay and then it
eventually went on up to about 80,000
and then I was worried about coming home
because I thought my wife would turn me
in I met her backstage she doesn't seem
like the type